الى المؤتمر الصحفي لمتحدث العسكري دان
هجس قاده حماس اضافه الى ذلك استهدفنا
عددا من الاهداف الخاصه لحزب الله في جنوب
لبنان ومن ضمنها نقاط عسكريه خاصه
بالتنظيم وقمنا برد على مصادر اطلاق
النار
ومنذ بدايه
الحرب كما بدايه الحرب لن نقبل بالتهديد
من الحدود الشماليه قلنا ذلك ونحن نعني
ذلك اريد ان اتطرق الى القضايا التي تحدثت
عن المراحل المختلفه للحرب قبل عده اسابيع
في تحدثت عن جيش الدفاع في شمال قطاع غزا
وكيف فككنا قدرات حماس العسكريه هناك في
الشمال ما زال
ما زالت ما زال مخربين لماس يعملون وايضا
نحن نعمل بطريقه مختلفه وايضا بطريقه قوات
مختلفه من اجل ان نحقق الهدف نحن نركز في
هذه المرحله في مركز قطاع غزه وفي هو في
معسكرات الوسطى في جنوبي قطاع غزه في
منطقه خانيونس والحديث هو عن عمليات
عسكريه مركبه وايضا هناك قتال عنيف ايضا
في في المركز والجنوب الحرب ستتواصل في
خلال العام 24 في مركز قطاع غزه ق جيش
الدفاع تركز الجهود في المعسكرات الوسطى
في البريج والقوات هناك معمل لانتاج
الاسلحه ونفق تحت الارض الموجود على على
بعد 30 مترا تحت الارض وفي هذا المصنع
هناك صواريخ بعيده المدى
وصواريخ وايضا في هذا المختبر وكان هناك
المحور الذي يتحدث عن صلاح الدين الذي
تكون فيه المساعدات الانسانيه من رفح الى
الشمال حماس بنى هذه المصانع الارهابيه
على المحور الانساني من تحت الارض وفوق
الارض وايضا في المناطق الموجوده فيها
المدنيين المصانع في المناطق المدنيه نحن
وجدناها وفكنا ونحن في هذه المرحله
وسنواصل العمل بهذه الطريقه الحديث عن
مخرطه الاكبر ولانتاج الاسلحه التي
وجدناها منذ بدايه الحرب كانت هي مرتبطه
بانفاق تحت الارض هكذا تم نقل الاسلحه في
مختلف انحاء قطاع غزه انتاج الصواريخ التي
تم اطلاقها لمنطقه المركز ومناطق اخرى في
كافه مناطق اسرائيل نحن سنواصل العمل هكذا
ضد الت ضد حماس وانتاج الاسلحه له وايضا
في ضد الار الارض وضد حماس في كل قطاع غزه
اسئله اريد ان اسالك فيما يتعلق بكلامك هل
اسرائيل تحولت الى المرحله الثالثه من
الحرض وهل هذا يعني الضغط الاكبر من اجل
تحرير المخطوفين
وايضا كيف نسمع ذلك عن طريق نيويورك تايمز
الاخدام
الكلمات
وبالاحسان انا اوضحت الامور بطريقه مرتبه
وواضحه نحن انهينا في الشمال تفكيك البنى
العسكريه لحماس هذا امر هام جدا وايضا
بكثير من القوات والقوات الاحتياط وايضا
في الشمال نعمل ما زلنا نعمل لانه يوجد
هناك ارهاب ليس عن طريق تركيبه عسكريه ليس
بطريقه منظمه ولكن هناك حرب نحن نواصل
العمل في هذه المنطقه وايضا بقوات مختلفه
نحن نركز الان في الجنوب وفي المركز في
خانيونس ومنطقه مركزيه نركز عليها تحت
الارض وفوق الارض الحديث هو عن ضغط عسكري
مهم جدا وقوي جدا وما عملنا به اليوم في
معسكرات الوسط هناك كانت معارك عنيفه
ومركبه وتدمير القدرات العسكريه لحماس وفي
هذه المرحله المرحله الثانيه والانتقال
الى المرحله
الثالثه الحرب في خلال العام 24 ستستمر
بطريقه مختلفه وايضا تم ابعاد عدد من قوات
الاحتياط نعمل بطرق مختلفه حسب ما هو
مطلوب من الناحيه العمليه ونحن نعمل في
نهايه الامر نعمل عن طريق الافعال وليس
بالكلمات
والاحرف لماذا الجمهور يجب ان يسمع ذلك عن
طريق نيويورك تايمز انا بلغت المراسلين
الاجانب دخلتهم الى غزه الى المناطق انتاج
الاسلحه ليروا باعينهم كيف هذا يقوم حماس
باستغلال المحور محور السلام ونقل
المساعدات
واوضحت لهم ورايتهم كل ما يقوم به حماس هم
يسالون اسئ على المراحل وكما تم عرض ذلك
وانا اوضحت هذه المراحل وهذا الايضاح يمكن
ان يتعلق بالمرحله الثانيه والثالثه انا
اتحدث عن الجمهور الاسرائيلي وانا اعتقد
اننا يجب ان نري الجمهور في اسرائيل
الافعال
وال النتائج كيف نفكك حماس وكيف نصل
الجهود نواصل الجهود من اجل اعاده
المخطوفين من الناحيه العسكريه ومن
الناحيه
الاستخباراتيه
هل لش الدفاع بقتل قائد رضوان قوه رضوان
في جنوب لبنان في حزب الله وهو قائد هذه
القوه هل يمكن حسب ما
تعرف ان تكون هناك عمليات
خاصه انا لا اتطرق الى ما تم نشره في
وسائل
الاعلام نحن يجب ان نعمل من اجل ان نبعد
تهديد في الحدود الشماليه وان نحقق الشروط
تمكن سكان الشمال من العوده الى بلاد
بلداتهم بطريقه امنه ونحن نتقدم نحو هذا
الهدف ونعمل ذلك بالافعال وليس بالكلمات
فيما يتعلق على محور فيلادلفيا ات القتال
يستمر في خلال العام 24 وهكذا نركز يجب ان
نعمل في مناطق اخرى بطريقه مختلفه وهذا
يحتاج الى موائمه اخرى ونصل الى كل مرحله
ومرح
من اجل ان نحقق اهداف
الحرب
هل تم القضاء على في جنوب
لبنان لا اتحدث عن ما نشر في وسائل
الاعلام نحن نعمل في الحدود الشماليه
بالامس ما حدث في الدفاع وما حدث في
الهجوم نحن نبلغ الجمهور كما نبلغ بكل شيء
في
ايضا التوجيهات الجبه الداخليه لا تغيير
ونحن نبلغ الجمهور نواصل العمل من اجل ان
نحقق الشروط الافضل الشروط الامنيه الافضل
من اجل ان يعود السك ان يعادوا السكان الى
هذه المناطق شكرا ومساء